deux mois après son entrée en vigueur on
peut maintenant évaluer combien de
québécois ont reçu l'aide médicale à
mourir une dizaine de code patients qui
ont choisi cette voie là pour gaétan
barrette c'est la preuve que l'accès
existe même s'il reconnaît qu'il y à des
hésitations chez certains médecins
les équipes sont en place partout et que
les choses se déroulent correctement
avec oui je plonge en convient la
lourdeur que vous mangez dépôt final le
rapport qu effectivement il ya des
difficultés par rapport à l'accès à
l'aide médicale à mourir un problème
reconnu par plusieurs médecins
actuellement il semble avoir peu de
médecins qui sont ouverts a accepté une
demande est d'accompagner la personne
sap ea est assez long long terme de
jours pour trouver un médecin qui
accepte de prendre la demande comme par
exemple dans une partie de la montérégie
les médecins qui se sont ouvertement dit
disponible à évaluer l'école y en a pas
beaucoup et c'est entre nous dans le
territoire c'est moins d'un pour cent
des médecins la réticence est peut-être
le plus forte que prévu l'énorme
distance entre discuter de ce sujet
l'aude de penser que c'est bien du bon
sens et de tenir là soit maintenant les
mains posé le geste pour un patient la
bataille juridique entre un groupe de
médecins et le gouvernement du québec
avant noël a aussi contribué à semer le
doute et plein xixe moi je veux bien le
faire mais je n'ai pas l'âme d'un
morgenthaler j'ai pas envie de me taper
une saga judiciaire est certain il était
impliqué l'aide médicale à mourir de
peur de se faire référer les cas de
leurs collègues moins enclins à poser le
geste les gens veulent pas être
identifiés comme étant le médecin qui
fait de la médicale à mourir dans son
milieu être clairement
pointée du doigt seule une partie des
médecins ont été formés pour l'aide
médicale à mourir
certains pensent qu'il faut leur donner
le temps de s'adapter
moi je pense que ça peut s'améliorer
parce que on est au début de
l'application de la loi
le virage prendra du temps aussi pour la
population qui ne comprend pas encore
très bien
les services qui sont maintenant offerts
devient le gouvernement comprend qu'il
doit mieux informer la population sur
cette aide médicale à mourir
et selon nos informations le
gouvernement va lancer une campagne
d'information à la fin février sur
l'aide médicale à mourir mais aussi qu
en tête d'autres éléments de cette loi
sur les soins de fin de vie comme par
exemple les directives médicales
anticipées qui permettent dès maintenant
des québécois de refuser par écrit toute
forme d'acharnement thérapeutique
sauf qu'il faudra sans doute du temps
avant que les médecins eux se sentent
plus à l'aise avec cette pratique là
j'ai parlé avec une dizaine de médecins
dans le cadre de la préparation de ce
reportage la majorité sont plus ou moins
à l'aise avec l'aide médicale à mourir
parce qu'on m'explique au téléphone que
ses médecins l'ont été entraînées et
formées à prolonger la vie donc l'aide
médicale à mourir céline c'est un virage
important
certains ont l'intention de faire ce
virage mais d'autres médecins me disent
et ils ont le droit d'ailleurs au sens
de la loi de refuser dans l'avenir
d'appliquer ou d'offrir l'aide médicale
à mourir
ça reste une question encore délicate
mercy et david bonne soirée